so wait i gotta ask okay because i
remember the exact meeting where you
asked me
have have you she asked me in a meeting
have you ever considered moving to japan
yeah we're just
casually talking just casually talking
but did you have that prize money and
that
competition in mind
are you allowed to tell us how much you
got i think okay so like
people will say oh it's not that much
but it was like i think they told me
it's like oh the prize is going to be
like
that's not that's like that's like
that's like a decent bonus
that's not bad but it's actually 500.
but what i want to know is how you
manage to convince them
because we as we've all talked about
japanese companies are [ __ ] difficult
they never want to train anything to try
anything new and convincing japanese
companies to send over like three or
four
annie tubers and just sponsor their
visas and
well i think uh you guys have been
working with like book walker for at
that point like two
three years already yeah so i had data
and like
yeah but as we know that we know we
audiobook that that's not always the
case all right like that's not
guaranteed
that wasn't enough though this is like
three years worth all right
never enough it's all about that data
yeah god damn it
the excel sheets exactly excel sheets
and powerpoints
and so i think in the back of their mind
they were already thinking like oh if we
had this business
it would be interesting and my superior
boss at that time was like giving me a
tip oh maybe you should submit
that idea because maybe they're thinking
about it yeah and i was like
okay i guess i have enough data so let's
do it
and then i won the thingy and then
did you have like was it like an
apprentice type pitch where you had to
like go into like a boardroom meeting
and yeah yeah yeah
i attended one yeah oh really yeah i was
uh
the like first week i moved here they
were like do you want to come to this
thing
yeah then you met mr cotton call it like
yeah i meant like yeah yeah it was weird
because i just sat down in like the most
like
like sterile room you can imagine
imagine like
just like 100 200 japanese businessman
in the quietest room in your life and i
came in
because i came in midway so i was making
so much [ __ ] noise just trying to sit
down
of course my my seat was in the middle
yeah you were like the only
non-asian i was like the only like
i was the only one not on the suit of
some sort as well
so i come in with like my t-shirt and
jeans
i'm like sorry excuse me excuse me sat
down
and then uh one of the japanese people
kept translating in my ear and i was
like just stop translating we're making
too much noise and people are looking at
us just like
yeah i'll just i'll just pretend like i
know what yeah but they were all really
good sports about it they were nice to
meet you
like that we had like a new business
plan format document you fill it out
and then within that i think it's like
over 200 maybe around 200 applicants
and then it narrowed down to like 50 and
then when you're the top
50 they narrow it you don't do anything
you just like
make like a three year uh business plan
yeah
when why did i go again there was free
food and drink
that was really good sushi and free beer
yeah that was like pretty good
food and drink i'll go to anything yeah
yeah exactly okay not gonna lie right
you were bored probably i was really i
had no internet they didn't know right
yeah
they weren't there i think i felt bad
because i've been crashing on joey's
couch for like a week i felt really bad
that was bothering him so much
that's fine but yeah
and then okay right this is the thing
right company parties at least in japan
they don't spay any expense with food
and drink like they like they do such
good food and drink
okay maybelline's a food snob i don't
count her opinion yeah yeah yeah it was
good
it was good okay okay but like they have
like bomb food and drink
like they'll yeah like restaurant
quality like food just there for you and
you're like yeah okay yeah
it is a restaurant though well no it's
like a hotel and they just bring in a
plateau and you just like dig
in yeah it's like sweet and all you can
drink and alcohol yeah
yeah yeah that's good people awkward
people
in the the uh japanese women taking
photos because oh yeah
they were like they're like this is the
guy who made the yowie the one
to check for the sex noises the book
walker like support team
i think they're mostly women and then
that's so weird this is the man
they're like all fangirls of you i think
they're 93 let's go let's go confused
because like none of them could speak
english so i was like why
why are you listening to my some of them
are like for the reason why they knew
about you was because i think
last year when we did the first
audiobook uh they were playing it
on speaker because they would get like
emails from customers saying oh i don't
know how to play this mp3 and so they're
like oh
let's check if there's a problem and
they play it and they just end up
playing it on speakers
they play the new one on speaker one has
like a hardcore sex scene like yeah i
don't
know because uh what is it coronavirus
so they played on the speakers at home
yeah probably
that was weird because then i was just
eating and then they were like can we
take a picture and i'm like who are you
so did you expect to win the competition
at all or was it like a [ __ ] surprise
for you
yeah uh kind of a surprise i guess
i knew i was the best no no like
well my my boss at the time was saying
like oh you have like
maybe like a high probability because
yeah he
was the one reviewing the other business
thing oh okay so maybe he helped me a
lot
i mean it's a pretty radical idea right
especially in like such a traditional
company like power right so do you know
other ideas you were competing against
yeah it was they're kind of like manga
service
like manga subscription or something
like that like i would be good as well i
mean that would be good for japan